hello and welcome this is daniel
and welcome to another video made
exclusively for youtube now
in this video i'm very excited um to be
starting a new series that i hinted
hinted at in previous videos and in this
series
i will be examining common mistakes the
most common mistakes
that chess players in the beginner and
intermediate levels
tend to make and i haven't decided how
many of these videos
i'll produce but probably it'll be on
the order of 10
and what i'll do is each video will be
dedicated to one particular mistake that
is very very common at the beginner and
club player levels
and in order to illustrate this mistake
i'll draw on my own tournament
experience
i'll show how i was frequently the one
committing these mistakes
uh what i learned from these games in
which i committed them
and how we can learn from that
experience
um in order to try to minimize those
mistakes so
without further ado um
i present to you the first mistake that
i'd like to talk about
which in short is forgetting
that tactics in the end game exist
now let's unpack that statement for a
second what does that mean well
i'm not going to delve too deeply into
defining what an end game is
you probably have a good understanding
of what that is it's a position
generally without queens
and generally with a limited amount of
material on the board
and when there is a limited amount of
material on the board what
generally tends to happen is that you
know because of the limited resources
players assume that
you can kind of switch off your tactical
detector there's going to be no danger
to the kings
there's going to be no abundance of
tactical threats no combinations no
sacrifices and
all of that stems from the fact that
well other than the king there's simply
not that many pieces left on the board
and it's crucial to remember that end
games
are hot beds of tactics and combinations
and even though there might not be a lot
of pieces left on the board
tactics are still extremely prevalent
and you have to keep your tactical
detector switched on
even when you think that you're safe and
the position in front of you is a great
illustration that it's a game that i
will never forget
now this position i had the black pieces
uh against
an international master from france
anthony balesh
and we're looking at it from anthony's
perspective
this game was played in philadelphia
2009. as you can see i was
rated approximately 2300 so you know i
was already pretty high rated
and i had played a very very good game
and reached an end game that in my mind
was very easily drawn
now what immediately should jump out at
you is the fact that white is up a pawn
however it's a pretty lame pawn if i may
say so myself it's this age pawn
and there's very very few pieces left on
the board now
if you have a nodding acquaintance with
theoretical end games that you will know
that simply having an h pawn and kings
is a dead draw
so trades here are in black's favor and
i figured that if i could just rid
myself of the immediate threats
then i should have no problem securing a
draw and of course i was right
now the next question is well what are
these immediate threats
let's imagine that it's white to move in
this position pause the video for a
second try to figure out what it is that
white's going to do here
well it's not too hard to realize that
white has a very very serious threat
he's threatening to play rook h4 check
king has to move to g8
and now white has checkmate knight e7
checkmate so you can see that
checkmate's do a rise in the end game
and
notice how the king on g6 is
facilitating this whole enterprise
without the king
black's king would have would have had
an escape square and f7
now of course i saw this i didn't miss
this because i also knew my opponent had
played rook before
i smelled a rat and so i figured he was
threatening checkmate
now i thought okay all that i really
need to do
is cut into this mechanism somehow now i
figured well i can't really
defend the square on h4 so what i can do
i thought is i can protect the e7 square
and so i played the very sensible
looking move rook to e8
and my idea was that after rook h4 check
king g8
my opponent would no longer be able to
give me a check on e7 with the knight
that would simply give up the knight
and all other attempts that my opponent
has in this position fall by the wayside
if he goes knight f6 check well it looks
like a fork but
the reality is i just take then i swing
my rook back now in
future videos i'll talk about these
types of end games for now suffice it to
say that
black is a very very easy draw because
white simply cannot make progress
black's going to give a bunch of checks
on the
back of the board to the white king and
once again rook trades are in blacks
the rook trade is in black's favor so i
would i would have had no problem
securing the draw here
so i and if white doesn't go if if after
a rook to e8
in this position y doesn't go knight f6
and let's say white
um swings his rook to g4 for example
well white is actually liable to get
even a worse position because i'm going
to give him a check on e6 i'm going to
push the king back from g6
and white actually has to be careful
here to make a draw because if he plays
king f5
once again never switch off your
tactical detector rookie 5 check is a
fork
king has to move back rook takes d5 and
now white has a very arduous task
of making a draw in this position which
by the way is possible but not easy
and if in this position after rookie 6
jack white
goes kh5 well among other things black
can simply go rook h6 check
skewering the king and picking off the
pawn
and draw agreement is on the cards
now in playing rookie 8 i had only
checked
that i was stopping the threat of rook
h497 and i had also made sure that the
move king f7
simply ran into rook cafe checking
essentially why it has to go back
but what i didn't do was explicitly
check for other
tactics i had only thought of it
in the sense of defending the e7 square
i didn't stop for a second say wait a
minute
let me look for some other tactical
possibilities in this position
and it turns out that white has an
absolutely stunning tactical idea
that turns the tables and actually wins
the game for white
once again i encourage you here to pause
the video take your time
and try to come up with this dastardly
move that my opponent sprung on me in
this position
now hopefully you were able to switch on
that tactical detector of yours
and realize that black's king is
actually still very much in grave danger
now the key
insight that i failed to make is that
the rook the black rook is
tied to the eighth rank and what does
that mean it's tied to the eighth rank
well that means
if the rook moves anywhere along this e
file let's imagine that the rook
ends up on e1 well then white has
backrank checkmate
uh black has apologies for this not sure
what this is
whoa okay my computer is
acting up there we go i think we're good
now uh white has
rook v8 check and it's background
checkmate i can make the very effective
defensive move rookie eight followed by
bishop
black is very close to drawing but
unfortunately ruby takes f8 wins the
game
and that might not seem like it's
important but
in fact it's extremely important why is
it extremely important because
white can use the fact that the rook is
tied down to play the brilliant move
knight e7 and when this move was played
i realized immediately
what was going on now what is going on
well white has posed the familiar threat
of checkmating on the side of the board
with rook h4
okay and black simply has no way of
stopping that
without giving up his bishop for example
which is of course disastrous
in addition white is still going to
checkmate black on h4 that doesn't even
help
and if i take on e7 and of course this
is what i missed and white has rook bhak
with checkmate to follow and if you look
at this position closely it's hard to
believe
but there's nothing that black can do
black cannot muster up sufficient
resources
to stop both threats at the same time if
he tries bishop h6
well that doesn't help because white
takes on h6 and if i take the knight now
nothing's changed this is still
checkmate after rookie rook takes e8
so amazingly the move 97 wins the game
for white
and i simply after staring at the
position for a couple of minutes
resigned
now if we go back to this position with
that understanding
we can now let me just remove these
arrows to make it
easier to visualize to make it easier to
look at this position
this arrow doesn't want this arrow
doesn't want to leave um
let me try to make it red first
make it green first ah it's okay
whatever i'll just leave this there oh
that's because it's white's most recent
move that's why
chess base has this thing where it just
shows you the most recent move in the
narrow
um what could black have done here well
had i realized that the king needs a lot
of space
there's a lot of moves here that draw i
could play the move rook to a8
and the idea is that 97 now meets with
rook a6 check pushing the king out of g6
um black could even play the move rook
to f1
and the idea is that rook b8 check meets
with rook f8 white hasn't gained
anything and if white goes
h4 check king g897 this is no longer
checkmate
as it used to be because black has
vacated this f8 square for his king
if white goes knight e7 here trying to
set up the same threats well again very
clearly this is not the same thing
because black and push off white's king
with rook g1 check
and then black is going to have the h7
square for his king so there were a lot
of moves here that
that drew i could have moved the rook on
the eighth file on the eighth rank i
could have moved the rook on the f file
all of that would have drawn anything
except the move that i played
so if you think about it i think that
the root cause of this mistake wasn't
just a random blunder it was the fact
that i wasn't checking for
mating tactics in this end game other
than the immediate threat of rook h4
because i assumed
that due to the limited resources my
opponent had there wouldn't be any such
combination
even possible and that is a big mistake
that i see made in a lot of games by a
lot of players
as soon as a lot of pieces come off the
board they stop looking for checkmates
they stop looking for combinations they
stop looking for sacrifices
they stop looking for attacks on the
king all of those things
are very much prevalent in end games in
fact a single king and pawn
can already mount an attack on the enemy
king that may sound absurd
but hopefully this example has convinced
you otherwise i remember that evening i
was
incredibly upset after this game but i
never forgot that lesson from that game
on
and although i still blunder a lot in
the end game
it rare is the occasion now that i
forget to check
for tactics and for combinations even
with a very limited amount of pieces on
the board
so this was our sort of first common
mistake that we've discussed which is
for getting to check for tactics in the
end game
i hope that you've enjoyed this video in
this example
in future videos we'll be talking about
other mistakes we'll be looking at other
examples this of course
is still a little bit experimental for
me but i hope that everybody was able to
take something out of it
and even if not then perhaps you just
enjoyed this nice little combination
i think 97 really is a beautiful move um
in retrospect of course i didn't think
so during the game
so uh in any case i hope you enjoyed i
would very much look forward to hearing
from you in the comments below any kind
of constructive criticism is very much
welcomed as this
is a new series and
uh above all whatever you do remember do
not
forget to check for tactics in the end
game
thank you